um I just got a question for you man I
just want to pick a bone with you uh I'm
gonna be straight up about it man uh uh
um like I feel like you're talking to my
girl
she keep texting somebody and and they
keep plopping up as like the Pluto Emoji
but I'ma just be I'm a man at first you
know what I'm saying I'm a man first so
I'm Gonna Be A Man About about the
situation and I'm gonna go ahead and
address it are you with her bro
and I mean it is what it is uh I charge
it to the game man
we need a picture of her
take it out for sure yeah cause I don't
even know her name so I gotta see the
face you know how these women is these
days you never know
you never know